[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday September 13th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
in recent months Instagram has gotten
criticism from some users including
celebrities like Kylie Jenner and Kim
Kardashian for trying to copy tick
tock's video Centric style in July CEO
Adam osari told users in a video posted
to Instagram that the platform had heard
their concerns but that video was an
important part of its future I need to
be honest I do believe that more and
more of Instagram is going to become
video over time we see this even if we
change nothing we see this even if you
just look at chronological feed if you
look at what people share on Instagram
that's shifting more and more to videos
over time if you look at what people
like and consume and view on Instagram
that's also shifting more and more to
video over time even when we stop
changing anything so we're gonna have to
lean into that shift but to do that
Instagram and its parent company meta
need to get more people using its short
form video feature Instagram reels
and according to a document reviewed by
The Wall Street Journal that summarizes
meta's internal research on reels that's
not going as well as the company would
like here to discuss what we found and
why Instagram is so focused on this
pivot is wsj Tech reporter Megan
bobrowski
Hi Megan thanks for joining me thanks
for having me Zoe start us off with a
bit of background I mean how popular are
reels now and how does it compare to
kind of the the usage time that we see
for tick tock yeah Instagram reels the
company says that they've been growing
you know in popularity but according to
an internal document that was published
in August the reels are watch time is
nowhere close to the hours that are
being spent on Tick Tock so on Instagram
the document says that users are
spending about 17 million hours a day
watching reels and so on ticks Hawk
users are spending almost 200 million
hours a day on Tick Tock so that's more
than 10 times the amount of time users
are spending on Tick Tock versus on
Instagram reels I mean that's a
significant difference what is meta
Instagram's parents say about that so
they say that the data about the viewing
hours is outdated and not Global in
scope but they also declined to give new
numbers or updated numbers can you tell
us a little bit about how we know this
information and how we know about
Instagram's plan for dealing with reels
and trying to make it more popular
yeah so there's this document that was
published internally in August called
The Creator real State of the Union and
it said that Real's engagement over the
past four weeks had actually been
falling by about 13 and it also said
that most reals users have no engagement
whatsoever what are creators saying
about their experience using it or maybe
choosing I guess not to use it yeah so
younger creators for sure you know take
talk is their platform this is where
they post and so some users will repost
their tick tocks to Instagram but
Instagram does not like when users do
that they want users to be creating
original content for Instagram and so
what they'll do is they'll downrank
reposted content which means that less
people are going to see it so for the
story I interviewed a Creator who does
really well in Tick Tock and so he
posted
the same video across Tick Tock
Instagram reels YouTube shorts and
Snapchat Spotlight and it got millions
of views on every single platform except
for Instagram reels and so this I think
is an example of you know not posting
original content is Instagram saying
it's going to make it so you don't get
as many views but at the same time this
Creator was saying you know no one's
going to make original content for
Instagram it's a lot of time it's a lot
of effort and you know when you're not
already seeing the payoffs of it sort of
what's the point but at the same time
there's some creators who have been able
to slightly tweak their content or to
emphasize certain parts of it and that
does seem to get them results on the
different platforms so what is Instagram
trying to do to convince some of these
creators to post more original content
to their platform so Instagram announced
last year that it was going to be
opening this one billion dollar fund to
pay creators and it's it's bigger than
you know tick tocks which is supposed to
tick tock's fun is going to pay out one
billion dollars over the next three
years but in terms of what the internal
documents Show Instagram reels so far
has paid out 120 million dollars and the
company says that you know this number
is dated this isn't cracked and it also
doesn't factor in payments to Facebook
creators as some listeners probably know
meta has been struggling with
advertising Revenue over the last year
or so how much of a push is this move
into short form videos to get more
advertising how is that impacting this
decision so meta's ad business is still
comparatively doing well I mean they do
generate more Revenue per user than Tick
Tock does and so I mean on Instagram
alone they're generating more than 21
billion dollars in Revenue a year
whereas Tick Tock is estimated to only
be bringing in about three billion
dollars so they're bringing in Instagram
alone is bringing in nearly seven times
as much revenue as Tick Tock is and
that's because they have a bit of an
older audience so people with more
disposable income who are going to be
more likely to buy the products that are
being advertised on Instagram and so
they can charge higher rates for those
ads but at the same time you know meta
is obviously facing some headwinds from
the Privacy policies that Apple ruled
out last year and so they can't track
users across apps as well as they used
to be able to so they're having trouble
delivering personalized ads and tracking
how All Those ads are doing last year
they said they thought it would be a 10
billion dollar hit to their revenue if
that does happen and that's true that's
gonna definitely bring them much closer
down to where tick tock's revenue is I
want to talk about something connect
connected to this a little bit the
perception of Instagram because you know
meta has always kind of been focused on
how their platform is perceived by its
users did any of the internal documents
kind of look at how users see the
platform right now yes So Meta surveys
users about their perceptions of of the
business and this is something that
they've done for years and so the
portion of Instagram users who think
that the company cares about them fell
about 50 from 2019 it fell from 70 in
2019 down to about 20 earlier this
summer so only a fifth of Instagram
users think that the company cares about
them and the other survey question
whether the people think that you know
the product is good for the world that
score fell about 15 percentage points
from 2019 and that sits right now about
slightly over 45 so it's not only that
meta is struggling to implement these
new products and features that they
really do need to succeed they're also
struggling to keep perception about the
company positive and to make users feel
good about the company
all right that's our reporter Megan
babrowski thanks so much Megan thanks
for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]